>> Tucker: WEEKLY STANDARD
FOUNDER BILL DOES TOLL
CALLED HAMILTON 68 AND IT'S
DESIGNED, THEY CLAIM, TO
COMBAT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION ON TWITTER.
BUT IT'S HAVING BIT OF A
HARD TIME AND SPREADING
DISINFORMATION OF ITS OWN.
FOR EXAMPLE, HAMILTON WAS
BEHIND THE CLAIM THAT THE
RELEASE THE MEMO CAMPAIGN TO
EXPOSE FISA ABUSE BY THE FBI
WAS JUST A RUSSIAN PLOT WITH
NO SUPPORT FROM ACTUAL
AMERICANS.
GLEN GREENWALD HAS BEEN
COVERING THIS.
IS HE A CRITIC OF WIDESPREAD
HYSTERIA ON THIS QUESTION
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
GLEN, THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
MANY STORIES THAT FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS IN A NEWS
ENVIRONMENT LIKE THIS.
I'M GRATEFUL WHY YOU HAVE
BEEN ON THIS.
WHAT IS HAMILTON 68 AND WHAT
HAS IT DONE?
>> SO, I WROTE ABOUT IT WHEN
IT WAS FORMED NOT EVEN A
YEAR AGO.
LAST SUMMER.
BECAUSE IT WAS YET ANOTHER
EXAMPLE PROBABLY THE MOST
VIVID ONE YET OF THIS KIND
OF UNION BETWEEN DEMOCRATS
ON THE ONE HAND AND THE
NEOCONS ON THE OTHER.
I GUESS I SAID REUNIONS
SINCE NEOCONS BEGAN AS
DEMOCRATS AND WENT BACK TO
DEMOCRATS AGAIN.
IT'S ESSENTIALLY A GROUP
STARTED BY PEOPLE LIKE BILL
KRISTOL.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN LEADING
NEOCONS FROM BOTH POLITICAL
PARTIES.
CIA OFFICIALS.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BASICALLY
DISSEMATING DISINFORMATION
ON THE ENTIRE WAR ON TERROR.
LEAST RELIABLE MOST WAR
MONGERING PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON.
THEY SAID THE PURPOSE OF
THEIR GROUP WAS TO COMBAT
DISINFORMATION AND THE
ATTACK ON THE AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY BY RUSSIA AND
OTHER GROUPS.
AND THEIR MAIN KIND OF
FEATURE WAS THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THIS DASHBOARD CALLED
HAMILTON 68 THAT PURPORTED
TO TRACK THE ACTIVITY OF
RUSSIAN INFLUENCERS ON
TWITTER BY TRACKING 600
ACCOUNTS.
NOBODY KNOWS WHICH ACCOUNTS
THEY HAVE DESIGNATED AS
INFLUENCE OF RUSSIA.
THEY ARE NOT NECESSARILY
RUSSIAN.
THEY ARE JUST PEOPLE WHO IN
THE EYES OF BILL CROSS TOLL
AND
BID
BILL KRISTOL ANDHIS FRIENDS ESPU
BILL KRISTOL ANDHIS FRIENDS ESPE
BILL KRISTOL ANDHIS FRIENDS ESPR
BILL KRISTOL ANDHIS FRIENDS ESPS
BILL KRISTOL ANDHIS FRIENDS ESPI
BILL KRISTOL ANDHIS FRIENDS ESPA
OR PRO-RUSSIA THEMES.
AND THEY JUST CONSTANTLY
MAKE CLAIMS ABOUT WHAT
RUSSIA IS DOING ON TWITTER
THAT THE U.S. MEDIA IN THE
MOST SHOCKING WAY
UNCRITICALLY INGESTS AND
PUTS INTO THEIR HEADLINES AS
FACT ABOUT WHAT RUSSIA IS
DOING.
>> Tucker: SO THEY ARE
BASICALLY RUNNING THEIR OWN
PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGN
PURPORTEDLY DESIGNED TO
COMBAT PROPAGANDA.
WHAT'S THE AGENDA BEHIND
THIS?
I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED BY.
THIS.
>> IT'S TWO FOLD.
ONE IS THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
OBSESSED WITH THE IDEA THAT
WE SHOULD BE AT WAR WITH
RUSSIA FOREVER.
BACK IN 2008 WHEN THE
PRESIDENT OF GEORGIA
ATTACKED TWO PROVINCES, THAT
VIEW THEMSELVES AS MORE
ALIGNED WITH RUSSIA AND THE
RUSSIANS WENT AND CONFRONTED
THE GEORGIAN GOVERNMENT
ABOUT IT, PEOPLE LIKE JOHN
MCCAIN AND MARCO RUBIO AND
THAT WHOLE NEOCON CROWD BILL
KRISTOL WERE CALLING FOR
NATO TO GO TO WAR WITH
RUSSIA OVER GEORGIA.
THEY HAVE BEEN OBSESSED WITH
RUSSIA FOREVER AND WANTED TO
REINVIG RATION OF A NEW COLD
WAR.
THAT'S PART OF IT AND THEN
THE SECOND PART IS DOMESTIC
WHICH IS THAT WHATEVER VIEW
THESE DISLIKE, MAIMLY ON THE
LEFT WING OF THE PARTY
THAT'S ANTI-IMPERIALISM AND
ANTIWAR THE LEFT WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OR THE KIND
OF ISOLATIONIST PAY LOW
CONSERVATIVE WING OR
LIBERTARIAN WING OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, THEY WANT
TO SMEAR AS BEING ALIGNED
WITH THE KREMLIN.
WHATEVER VIEWS ARE ON THE
RIGHT WING OF THE PARTY LIKE
RELEASE THE MEMO ARE ON THE
LEFT WING OF THE PARTY LIKE
ANYTHING RELATING TO BERNIE
SANDERS, THEY WILL JUST
DECLARE TO BE A THEME OF
RUSSIA AND THEN ACCUSE
EVERYBODY WHO ADVOCATES IT
AMERICANS WHO ADVOCATE IT ON
TWITTER OF BEING PART OF A
KREMLIN DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN.
>> Tucker: YOU AND I ARE ON